le roi se prépare à quelques minutes de
se lancer sur scène Kaf Malbar est
entouré par son équipe il est détendu
tout sourire tout en décontraction c'est
l'esprit Dada house il s'apprête à
partager le moment présent
[Applaudissements]
il donne le ton avant même d'entrer dans
la lumière
lorsqu'il apparaît sur scène la foule
est un délire
le tempo de maloya trappes malbar a tenu
son public en haleine ils étaient tous
venus pour lui
obliger d'être là ce soir c'est pas la
même ambiance quand tu es assis tu vois
pas c'est pas le même point de vue mais
on profite quand même mais le plus
important c'est d'être ici ce soir quand
même alors c'est cool tu chantes les
couilles c'est bien de le voir en vrai
c'est un vrai artiste réunionnais ça
fait du bien
[Musique]
jusqu'à la dernière note la musique du
roi raisonnée dans le cœur des festivals
de monter chante pas vraiment donc de
monter des coupes une espèce qui fait
ben le café le mal barbe c'est moins
maintenant visage déçu le nom et après
cialisent suivre l'été accueillant tu es
chaleureux tu es comme mitter attend
voilà franchement big up mais c'est pour
ça encore sur un petit nuage Kaf Malbar
va pouvoir appuyer sur pause avant de
revenir nous promethyl avec de nouveaux
sons